we had this story from the post to
Millennial Bud light's anti-frat
marketing exec busted partying frat
style in leaked photos so apparently
someone had uh these photos or whatever
in an album for when they were partying
with this woman and they showed that
when she came out so let me slow down
and provide contacts for everybody
because we're entering a new segment
this VP came out amid the controversy
and said Bud Light was a dying brand and
we needed to make it inclusive and get
rid of that frat bro image that's funny
she is that frat bro bro image she lived
that life
and Bud Light is the number one selling
beer last year and the year before it
and so on and so forth so Bud light's
not a dying brand that it's absolutely
not true and this woman who claims she
wants to be inclusive and get away from
that frat bro culture is a part of that
culture now we've got a story piling on
she lied she lied she's an occult
ideologue who is exploiting this
position to take the top-selling beer in
the world and turn it into a woke woke
cult product to distribute a woke occult
product what they're really doing is
they're they're not worried about a
dying brand that's the LIE they're
taking over by infecting the largest
beer brand in the world and turning it
woke that's why I think if this
opportunity exists to to pounce on this
as they say and keep talking about it we
should but more importantly this story
about this woman shows the story's not
going away anytime soon the post
millennial ran the story I think New
York Post ran the story a bunch of news
outlets are going and the Daily Mail
they're they're saying this hey we're
making money covering this let's keep
doing it and that's the problem of the
internet age when people latch onto a
viral story and they won't let go it
won't stop no matter what you do it will
get crazier it will get worse and I am
hoping that the nightmare tornado of
viral memeology when someone comes to
hate something whips up into a frenzy to
the point where this VP is fired where
the marketing teams at Anheuser-Busch
are looking at a 10-point drop in their
stock when when when they're now
Fielding phone calls from their
investors being like why are we losing
this much money why isn't this going
away and they say
we're going to have to apologize and
when that happens what Anheuser-Busch
will signal to the entire world is we
screwed up we can't Embrace this
ideology we have lost too much money and
even if they could get loans it won't
matter if they can get endless ESG
Capital it won't matter because they'll
ship out products and the regional
stores will say I'm not going to carry
that my customers will Revolt I'll get a
bunch of people in front of my store
yelling at me get out of here and then
they cease to exist I don't think we're
anywhere near that it's one of the most
profitable beverage beverage companies
in the world with the top selling beer
but all we need is a couple a couple a
double digit percentage Point drop to
where Anheuser-Busch says clearly the
story won't go away and we've seen a
whole bunch of stories over the past few
years when people get obsessed with
something and refuse to let go and
you're wondering how is the story still
going viral how are they still talking
about it because we're going to keep
doing it because the people care about
it because the commentators make money
from doing it because the Tabloid media
makes money from doing it and the only
way out for Anheuser-Busch is an apology
I think the Daily Mail had a better more
accurate title for this particular story
they had rules for thee not for me Bud
Light exec demanding beer update it's
Friday image is seen partying at a 2006
Harvard Booze Fest and pounding shots
from condoms so uh yes that happened and
that's what everyone's talking about and
and to to go back to kind of Joe Rogan
here and to try to steal man his
argument I think what he's trying to say
is that he's maybe sick of cancel
culture he's maybe thinking that there
might be more important stories there
and I think on the other side
cancel culture has been weaponized I
think it's unavoidable and I think it's
at a point right now where sadly in the
culture War it is being used more and
more against individuals for doing less
and less things so to have a
counterbalance to it is I think what
you're arguing for Tim here and I'm
curious what the audience thinks do you
think that this is an issue that doesn't
really matter to you or do you think
that this is an issue that we must take
seriously in order to kind of hit back
against this larger culture War so I
don't know let's just see let's just see
the chat press number one if you think
that this is something that we should be
uh avoiding that there's bigger stories
there press number two if this is an
important issue to you that we should
take seriously I'm curious what people
say well my my view of it is
when when I heard that Joe Rogan cracked
open a Bud Light
the the most interesting reaction
actually was Howard Stern he didn't get
angry he didn't smack talk
he was he was confused I don't
understand is there something the story
that I'm missing there is but Kid Rock's
normal I'm sorry uh Howard Stern's
normal approach to culture War issues is
the right are a bunch of Nazi chuds
screw them etc etc
when Kid Rock shot up all that Bud Light
and said Fu Howard Stern didn't get mad
all of a sudden he said what's going on
am I missing something here that's
actually what he said am I missing some
of this story and he goes I've always
been the you know just you can be
whatever you want to be as long as you
just don't hurt anybody and therein lies
the point what Dylan Mulvaney is doing
is hurting people it's hurting children
Tick Tock is promoting an ideology that
tells kids to harm themselves and this
is a fact what we saw in Scandinavia was
that child medical transitions did not
work and so they abandoned it the
Tavistock Center uh clinic in the UK was
shut down because child sex changes were
not working but the United States is
behind the curve and they're still
promoting this and Tick Tock is
promoting Dylan Mulvaney to children
to then push this ideology on them
that's the issue with why it's bad that
Bud Light decided to sponsor Dylan
Mulvaney yeah Dylan just did a month ago
a video where he was dressed as a little
girl do singing a song from some musical
as a little piece or whatever yeah and
now they sponsored him for a beer
commercial but I think we're I think
we're almost saying two different things
now because I I'm not disagreeing with
verley anything you just said we should
press we should press I hope they drop I
hope that I I want it but boycott do all
that I'm I'm agreeing with you this is
insane we should do it what I'm saying
is the black pill though like there's no
way out there's no solution no that's
not what I'm saying there are solutions
but what I'm saying is that what this is
doing it won't be successful and let me
let me explain let's say Bud Light let's
say they do come out tomorrow and that
well back up we lost billions of dollars
hey guys put out a statement hey we're
sorry and no more of the dudes
pretending to be chicks on the beers
we're sorry sorry about that won't
happen again
now let's be honest here what's the
response to that the response to Bud
light's apology
is so much worse than anything the right
will be able to do to Bud Light with
sales when it comes to next two months
it would be that they'd have they'd have
actual violence because we all know
these commies come are violent that they
would they would have drivers being
assaulted that they would have mass
demonstrations every Tom Dick and
Harry's celebrity'd be on Instagram Bud
Light these Nazis that's the point they
can't afford to backtrack now because
they can't afford to offend the religion
of the state that is the one thing they
cannot afford to do and where you're
wrong is
if we get Budweiser to the point where
they apologize to us it means they fear
us more than them and they don't and
until we make them by their stock
dropping and their products not selling
and they realize their business can't
persist by offending their own audience
their own Market that means it has to be
sustained and persistent and it is the
easiest thing for anyone on the right to
do buy a different beer now that I agree
I look I agree this is the point I said
when Budweiser issues an apology to us
it means they are they are more scared
of losing their business from sales than
the violence of the left it is a fact
the the left uses violence to win the
culture War and the doj protects them
and the police protect them and if
anyone on the right so much as farts
they'll get arrested a guy can go to a
store in San Francisco with a garbage
bag and fill up product and they'll let
him go but if anyone dares try to stop
him they will get arrested Budweiser
knows that which means if it gets to the
point where their sales are gone because
we are their customers not so much me
but I mean it is regular
um like it it is not 22 year old college
kids for the most part although it to a
certain degree it is but we're talking
about people ages 25 to 80 years old and
I'm talking about the average point of
death for the app for the average male
who are buying beer products if they
decided that the ages of 21 to 24 are
more valuable than the entirety of their
market share then so be it let them take
a look at an 80 sales drop-off they
won't do it if the regional Distributors
say I will not carry a product if the
Affiliates say I'm not going to work
here anymore because we're not making
enough money and if the shareholders say
why did I lose 10 percent in two weeks
they will be forced to apologize knowing
the left will lose their minds and that
means the economic damage is scarier to
them than the left physical violence and
that is exactly the victory we need so
maybe maybe we lose the point is we must
persist in the easiest culture War
battle that's ever been laid before us
so that they are forced to apologize I
agree now that I agree with that 100 and
I will say this I will say this uh the
the trans Rights Movement
I do believe that it is actually a gift
from God for this country because I have
watched the right forever for my entire
life kind of dismissed the the newest
thing the newest culture War thing or
not take it that seriously or they'll
stop soon or surely there's an end to
this or it doesn't apply to me it's been
so easy to play that game the whole oh
I'm not gonna buy into any slippery
slope stuff I think this whole insane
movement has finally woken the right up
to that there is no end that this is not
the end this is this is not the end
either it gets worse I'm here it keeps
going down and down and down and down
and down that if we're going to get to
the place where we are telling children
and we're going to be telling young boys
just chop your penis off and you'll
become a woman I think that is finally
waking the right up to okay I'm not
dealing with bad I'm dealing with evil
and that is why the right has failed for
so long because bad May wake up in the
morning like that great CS Lewis
quote-un paraphrasing bad May wake up in
the morning and say you know I'm kind of
tired but demons do not demons don't
wake up and decide they've gone down the
drain enough because that's the
difference let me tell you because we we
did talk about this a bit the other day
as well yesterday was Ron Paul but
before that
I have gone on Twitter and I have
tweeted uh spay and neuter your children
to prevent overpopulation
not a peep from the left I have said I
actually am I don't mind abortion rights
and I think the left should have them
because they're ending their their
lineage and so the future will be
conservative not a peep nobody cared no
leftist said how dare you say something
so offensive
well the reality is they know it
and I think they're in many ways
that like they they know that abortion
and sterilizing their children will
result in less liberals and the future
being more conservative that's why they
have to go to the schools they don't
want to highlight the issue and say Tim
Poole said an awful thing because it
puts in the mind of all the Liberals
that hey wait a minute we are getting
rid of our kids now of course the
response from liberals is Tim liberals
have children too and I'm like oh yeah
but like 1.2 on average for every two
adults whereas conservatives have two
for two adults so conservatives
certainly aren't um at replacement
levels they're at or slightly below but
Liberals are substantially lower and
have them over the past 20 years you add
to the fact that you are pro-abortion
and more likely to have an abortion or
sterilize yourself or your kids it's
going to go even lower and given a long
enough time the math is simple you will
your your ideology and your family
lineage and your genealogy will cease to
exist now here's the point they not once
have smeared me over saying things like
that but you know what they smeared me
over relentlessly Budweiser you know why
over Target the fact that a major
corporation for no reason for no reason
the number one selling beer
the fact that they decided to embrace
wokeness has resulted in a four
percentage Point stock drop off five
billion dollars is scary because there's
other companies that aren't as big as
Anheuser-Busch who who maybe and Ezra
Bush will be okay as other companies
couldn't handle that these other
companies couldn't say we can't handle
all our regional Distributors cutting
off our brand if we if we adopt this ESG
stuff we're going to go to business look
at the backlash I'm not going anywhere
near that that is the social pressure we
are trying to create right now and the
point is this I will push on this as
hard as possible because for once we are
seeing quite possibly the easiest
culture War battle ever before us you
don't got to go outside in fact quite
the opposite you don't even have to not
drive here you don't even have to not
buy beer go buy all the beer you want
just buy a different one yeah avoid
Anheuser-Busch Brands buy a local
Brewery be careful with those two by the
way because Anheuser-Busch has been
buying those up one of my favorite local
ones in Houston
brought up by Anheuser-Busch make sure
you look that up first yeah someone
published the list of all the companies
that they own and all the breweries that
they have and it's it's multiple tweets
of things I tweeted it we are changed so
people could see it there's a large
number right
and then and then so it's they're the
company's called a b Dash inbev that's
the new company called and then eye
patch McCain what's his name uh Crenshaw
was also promoting another beer owned by
uh by uh anhydra Bush right and Miller
Coors has done a lot of Pride stuff as
well exactly however I don't care as
much about that I don't care that you
know this is the funny they're like haha
Marjorie Taylor green you're saying by
Miller Coors but here's their LGBT Pride
ad and and my response is oh wow that's
really cool they did an LGBT Pride ad I
have no problem with that my problem is
that Dylan Mulvaney is targeting
children you want to sell beer to kids
yeah I got a problem with that you wanna
you wanna tell kids to sterilize
themselves I got a problem with that you
want to promote those ideas to kids I
got a problem with that and so if we can
simply say hey look man you know Dylan
can post whatever Dylan wants on Tick
Tock Budweiser can sponsor whoever they
want and then we won't touch their
products that's the market thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time